so let's take that for a second because
you are younger and you have so many
credits and you also grew up in the
industry how do you take that when
people do challenge you because I could
see people that have been here for years
and maybe there's some resentment and
they feel jealous starting to do these
attacks and I'm not saying that that's
right I'm just saying that that's the
nature of this town because it is tough
to live here maybe it's just human
nature I don't know I'd like Don to
think that but I mean I have a ton of
work experience so I think that kind of
speaks for itself in the short amount of
time that I've been working I've learned
so much and done so much I mean I've ran
crews of 92 150 people some of which
didn't even speak English and I managed
to get it all done so at then I dealt
with floods and crazy stuff so at the
end of the day if people want to hate on
me for what I do I feel like that's just
jealousy speaking and instead of trying
to put that negative energy towards me
they should put that negative energy
towards a script about why they want to
kill me or something and now they have a
horror movie they should do that that'd
be great um but ultimately I think they
should they should they should use that
energy for positive stuff creation and
to just be mad at somebody because
they're doing well it is is silly
because at the end of the day like
everybody has their peaks and valleys
I've done well sometimes I don't do well
but I continue to work hard and I
continue to push myself and keep going
and that's the important thing you have
to just keep going and I think when you
spend so much time getting mad about
somebody else's success you forget about
your own and you forget about focusing
on your own because I remember when I
first started doing this I saw you know
filmmakers and I was like well I don't
know why this person is getting like you
know a huge budget feature instead of
being genuinely happy for them and then
I started realizing no I should be
genuinely happy for them because then
doing that and then getting that feature
that proves that it's possible and that
proves that this is not just a fantasy
it proves that you can go and make a
little five thousand dollar movie
a huge budget feature you can go and
make a couple movies and win a bunch of
awards and suddenly become you know a
filmmaking sensation in horror whatever
genre you're doing and you can do that
you can make a little movie that goes to
Sundance you can do that and instead of
instead of being the type of person that
gets angry that other people are doing
that and you're not realize that it
could possibly be your turn later and
just fall in love with the idea that
it's still a possibility rather than a
fantasy when you encounter that
resistance let's say you're on set and
you're leading a crew of a number of
people how do you deal with it um I show
them professionalism and I show them
respect and I hope to get the same
respect back I remember I was working
with a key on one of my films I won't
say what position or who they are but
they were significantly older than me
and they they were like 50-54 and they
did not like the fact that a 21 year old
was telling them what to do so much so
that they would be like I'd asked them
to do something and be like will you go
yourself and I'd be like okay so I
I ended up you know putting up with it
and finding nice ways because I never
lose my cool on set I will never nobody
on my sets have ever seen me screaming
at anybody nobody has ever seen me you
know flip out if I have a problem with
somebody I pull them off to the side and
talk with them I have a sidebar about it
nobody sees me lose my cool and it's
important because when you're on set you
are the captain of the ship if you're a
director and you have to have a calm
cool easy breezy way of dealing with
things and if you don't and you're not
able to handle all the chaos then
everybody from your grips to your pas to
everybody feels that negative energy and
it brings them all down everybody feels
that the actors feel the actors feel it
the most so you have to always always be
able to expel that negative energy and
be on set and deal with it and I've
always had people that don't like how
young I am but when I show them a
professional courtesy and when
they are being a douche and I am NOT and
I'm being kind and and just explaining
my my thoughts and and what I want and I
exert you know confidence I'm not sure
if exerts the right word but confidence
I show confidence and at the end of the
day that's that's what gains their
respect and now that person who was
against me and didn't like me and was
much older than me would work with me
any day and has said many times they
want to work with me again at the same
person that same person and it's it's
important to to always show everyone
respect on your sets and always treat
everybody as equals no matter what their
position is I spend the entire day
before I start making a movie I spend
days looking through the entire crew and
cast list so I know everybody's names so
when I meet them I can say nice to meet
you and I say their name because I think
it's important that if I'm the director
that they feel special that I know who
they are no matter what if it's if it's
a 10 person crew or if it's a hundred
person crew I find it important to know
every single person from it my actors
even if they're add a player to the only
people i don't know are the extras
because they get cast the day before
sadly but i know i know the people that
are working with me and it's important
to show that and because they're out
there they're starting from the bottom
but will they'll be somewhere someday
too and you want to instill into them
that type of respect so that they will
show that to people when they have their
own crews and i think i think it's
really important to continue to do that
so when people are against me for my age
I kind of just laugh it off and show
them otherwise by how I how I handle
myself and how I'm talking right now and
being right now this is how I am on set
I never talk louder than this I talk
very calm collected and I think it's
important to stay that way and it's also
important to realize that
the people on your set you are the
captain of the ship but the people on
your set are your crew of your ship and
a captain is only as strong as their
crew and why you are surrounded by so
many creative in brilliant minds is
because film is a collaborative medium
it's a living breathing thing and just
because you didn't come up with the idea
to include something in your film or to
do a certain shot or to do a certain
thing doesn't mean that if somebody has
that idea and it's a good idea you
should just not do it because you didn't
have the idea it's your idea to include
it if it fits the overall vision so
listen to your navigator who's your DP
if your DP thinks that it's a much
better shot to do this your amount see
the shot see what it's like and realize
that it's important to collaborate
because you don't want to be so blind
with hubris that you're only looking
through a tunnel vision have your vision
have what you want and see if other
people's ideas can fit into that vision
because usually contention comes from
people feeling that they're not being
creatively heard
you